i was one of those people who was very  stressed out and career oriented and now  looking back i wish that i had spent my  time in my 20s to really figure out who  i wanted to be and the only way that you  can do that is by trying lots of things  and failing at them and having many many  many experiences and not worrying so  much about  the latter of your career trajectory  when you do that you become a more  robust individual you understand  different walks of life different  perspectives um you start to figure out  what you enjoy doing and what you don't  enjoy doing it's hard to intellectualize  that like you have to go into the world  and do things  to find out like oh that that's not what  i thought it was it's not for me or wow  this thing i never thought of before  like has led me into this other  direction which is fantastic